the supreme court just delivered the
biggest win for the second amendment and
for gun rights in almost 15 years
the case was the new york state rifle
and pistol association versus bruin and
the question concerned whether or not
new yorkers are allowed to bear arms to
carry a gun outside of the home the
decision was not close even roberts who
is the swing vote the squish of the
court he sided with the conservatives
6-3 decision the opinion written by
justice clarence thomas
it came down to a law in new york that
said that if you wanted to be able to
carry a gun you had to have
proper cause and you had to demonstrate
proper cause
but of course the the proper cause from
the second amendment is this when the
government is trying to take away your
second amendment rights that is proper
cause to exercise those rights a major
win for conservatives a major win for
the rule of law in an already excellent
supreme court term for the constitution
for conservatives as we all await with
baited breath the decision
in dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization the decision that could
overrule roe v wade i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
i'm michael knowles my favorite comment
yesterday is from king bubba who says
when they said we would own nothing and
rent everything they didn't say that
included our immune system very good
point that is true the world economic
forum really has been extraordinarily
efficient yes you will you will earn
nothing you will rent everything and you
will subscribe to netflix you'll
subscribe to your razer companies and
you will subscribe to the vaccines which
are so incredibly safe and effective
that you need to take
7 000 of them every single year just
take that jab it feels kind of like we
don't have as much control anymore feels
kind of like we don't have as much
privacy anymore well when you want to
take control of your communications
you've got to check out puretalk right
now go to puretalk.com enter promo code
knowles podcast right now let me guess
what you're paying for your cell phone i
would bet
it's somewhere around 80 bucks a month
maybe it's higher maybe it's 90 bucks a
month maybe it's a little lower but i
bet it's somewhere in that zone what if
i told you you could pay 20
per month for your cell phone
you're not gonna have to sacrifice your
phone you can get the brand newest
coolest iphone or whatever you want
you're not gonna have to sacrifice your
service you're gonna get the exact same
service as those big carriers that
you're paying big bucks for now how do
they do it because you're paying a
premium to those big cell phone carriers
for for stuff that you're not using if
you go to puretalk right now you will
get that great 5g service you get that
very very
cool phone you're not going to be
dropping calls all of a sudden
you're not going to have a terrible
service you're going to have really the
top shelf stuff you're just not gonna
pay money for stuff that you don't need
go to puretalk.com right now select a
plan enter promo code noel's podcast
love these guys they are totally totally
supporting this show and the voicemail
bag which is my favorite segment promo
code knowles podcast canon wles podcast
all one word puretalk.com puretalk is
simply smarter wireless
really really big win
it's almost sad that we have to
celebrate a win like this
it's it's sad because the second
amendment is pretty clear
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed i know that we redefine
all the words these days shall not be
infringed should be pretty clear
keep and bear arms should be pretty
clear and by the way we're not talking
about a bazooka or a nuclear weapon
we're talking about a regular gun
so the supreme court makes the right
decision here it's not even close it's a
6-3 ruling and then in a move that
if it's not unprecedented it's certainly
extremely unusual and it might be
unprecedented the biden doj came out and
said they disagree with the supreme
court
just shows you how stacked things are
for conservatives here this this is
coming
on the very day when senate democrats
passed the most radical gun control
legislation that they passed since 1994.
okay this on the day that the executive
branch comes out and says no we hate
your gun rights we want to we want to
get rid of them this as all the
corporations as all of the
institutions come out against your basic
second amendment rights and we need to
celebrate that the second amendment
hasn't been completely gutted a really
really basic right the right to defend
ourselves but we'll take the wins while
we can get them this was a slam dunk
though this one was
so clear from the perspective of the law
from the perspective of the constitution
from the perspective of centuries of
american history what did the democrats
have on their side
what what was pushing the the libs
argument here
i i would say pretty much
just this
land of the free home of the brave land
of the ar-15 home of kids in the grave
i've struggled to find the words keep
the disposition sunny i'm always trying
to turn the unfunny things funny but
laughing feels wrong hypocrisy is right
i gotta say something cause you're all
pro-life unless it's taken by a gunman
19 more tiny heartbeats stopped in their
alma mater you force kids into the world
then condemn them to slaughter we teach
our daughters how to hide when they
should be learning history then we're
surprised when it repeats itself it's no
mystery it's indifferent see them run
when asked how to combat the matters
he'll care about your rights they only
care about their status and they have us
where they can hold us packed in the
senate and scotus and acting focus focus
focus while we hopelessly focus on the
joke that is trying to feel safe in this
country i love my home but i don't know
if we'll truly become free if we can't
agree uncle sam's holding a bad gun the
nation's fighting for its soul are we
sure it ever had one
children dying in the school
but can you tell me why are they not
trying to change the room we're crying
but we're not fools
i am calling for a complete and total
ban on all theater kids until we figure
out what the hell is going on i
mentioned this clip i alluded to it at
the end of the show yesterday and i i
told you you had to prepare yourself you
had to give yourself a facial massage so
that that the cringe would not just be
stuck on your face permanently forever
listening to that watching that if you
had the misfortune of watching that with
your eye that's
i know i know it's really
challenging i think that's pretty much
the best argument the dems had to take
away our guns
that's it
that's what it also raises this question
what was the purpose of that video
what was what was the purpose of that
guy releasing that
hamilton impression you know that rap
singy songy political activism
was it to effect political change
or was it to just get clicks and clout
it was obviously the latter is that
video convincing anybody in the middle
no the people in the the ordinary people
the conservatives and the people in the
middle and in the center the only thing
they will take away from that video is
wanting to give that guy a swirly
they're they're not going to be
persuaded to give up their second
amendment rights but what did this guy
get he got a lot of clicks and he got a
lot of attention and i assume he wants
to be in a broadway musical or something
and maybe that'll work out for him
but that's it i mean that is the best
that they've got the left has
silly bizarre
outlandish appeals to emotion
and they've got the raw exercise of
power so they do control a lot of the
institutions and they use those
institutions to push their radical
agenda believe it or not
that video that gun wrap from that guy
that is not even the most
cringe-inducing video on the internet
right now
that honor would go
to the united states navy
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i am kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect if it's a signal
of acceptance and respect how do we go
about creating a safe space for
everybody
that's a good question a really good way
to do that is to use inclusive language
instead of saying something like hey
guys you can say hey everyone or hey
team
yeah and now that you say that another
way that we could show that we're allies
and that we accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns
the sound you're hearing right now is
general patton rolling over in his grave
old blood and guts about to become
reanimated so he can he can show up and
beat up whichever
navy officer okayed this video i i still
don't even really believe that this is
real
i have to think this is a hoax cooked up
somewhere except that we've seen this
kind of rainbow activism from the other
branches of the services and so the navy
seems to have followed suit here
a great way for you to a great way for
you to affirm
everybody's sexual desires and beliefs
meanwhile vladimir putin is just rolling
tanks through eastern europe hold on
we'll deal with that in one second first
though did you really call him a
pansexual when he's a transsexual
meanwhile xi jinping is just conquering
hong kong is conquering taiwan
is conquering
all of our interests in south china sea
hold we're going to deal with that in
just one second
first though
did you affirm that man's sexual
fantasies did you because that's we need
to take care of that first in 2013
women were not in combat positions women
were not allowed to be in combat
positions in the united states military
and in 2013 the obama administration
moved to put women in combat roles and
that was really really controversial and
a lot the republicans were against it
and even a lot of democrats were against
it
fast forward
nine years and we are here with our
sailors and the other servicemen too
having to sit through these bizarre
training videos where you have to
pretend that a dude can be a chick
nine years think about how fast that is
and think about two
how just insanely navel-gazing and
narcissistic it is i am coming to you
right now from santa barbara at
california i came up to santa barbara to
speak to the yaf uh high school
conference i'm gonna have to miss the
aft college conference because little
buddy knowles little baby number two is
coming out so i came up here i was i was
really pleased to be able to speak to uh
high school students the topic of my
speech was the narcissism of gender
ideology
and i hope you check it out i think it's
on on the yaf youtube channel now
we always talk about the absurdity of
transgenderism we talk about the
absurdity from a biological standpoint
the incoherence from a metaphysical
standpoint we don't really focus on the
narcissism of it it's just people
talking about themselves all the time
they're just focused on themselves and
the most base aspects of themselves
talking about their genitals and their
libido and their sexual desires ad
nauseam and it's sad and it's pathetic
and it's the sort of thing that that
children do the people who haven't
gotten an education that haven't grown
up do this is not the sort of thing we
should expect from adults it sure as
hell isn't the sort of thing that we
should expect from the united states
military
now
what i expect in my life
is to go home to my wonderful community
to my wonderful wife and my wonderful
house and sit down to a delicious meal
of good meat and when i want good meat
you know where i you know where i go
good ranchers right now head on over to
good ranchers
slash knowles use promo code knowles and
i'm gonna give you some meat that's
right
meat
care of michael for your fourth of july
right now if you head on over to
goodranchers.com use my code you will
get to
18 ounce prime center cut rib eyes free
with your order
these steaks can cost 50 bucks apiece
i'm giving you a hundred dollars of free
meat well it's really good ranchers is
doing it through my show through my
promo code right in time for the fourth
of july i absolutely love these guys
american company
100 american meat when sweet little lisa
is out of town and i don't know what am
i going to do what am i going to cook i
don't know i almost never cook you know
what i do my first my first instinct i
go for that freezer i get out my good
ranchers they've got great beef they've
got superb chicken i love they just i
actually go back and forth on which one
i like more they are absolutely fabulous
giving away two delicious ribeyes
normally would be fifty dollars per
stake or more from those other places
goodranchers.com slash knowles promo
code knowles you will get them for free
right now stop spending exorbitant
amounts of money on low quality meat at
the grocery store subscribe to
goodranchers instead you can buy the
meat just one off no big deal or you can
subscribe you save 25 on every box for
the life of your subscription to choose
however long you want you want to wait
in between the arrival of your meet
you're gonna love it i love these guys
they're phenomenal goodranchers.com
slash knowles promo code knowles
we are now approaching the 50th
anniversary of title ix you know title
ix is this way to give women lots of
distinct opportunities in educational
environments and in the most ironic
hilarious way to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of title ix joe biden has
decided to push
to extend the title ix protections
that go to women
to men who pretend to be women so joe
biden is celebrating the half century
anniversary of title ix by completely
destroying title ix and it's bad the
stuff that he's doing is bad and it's
bad to recognize this delusion of
transgenderism in federal law and it's
it's just wrong from a an ontological
and moral and legal standpoint it is but
it but it's kind of funny
it is we have to admit it's kind of
funny that we've gone full circle here
and had feminism completely destroyed by
the poisonous fruits that it put out
well over 50 years ago that that the
second wave of feminism put out it does
remind us too
you can't have it all you can't you
can't have everything this is a theme
i've talked about a lot i wrote a book
about it we talk about it in the show
society requires limits limits to our
speech limits to our behavior limits to
our institutions limits to our laws
limits to our rights limit you need
limits you need limits to liberty for
liberty if liberty is to have any sense
at all it needs to have limits if it
doesn't have limits it becomes
licentiousness and you lose the whole
system so what biden is proposing
is to change
uh title ix protections which protect
people on the basis of sex to protect
lgbtqi plus students from discrimination
based on sexual orientation gender
identity and sex characteristics this
according to biden's
department of education but you can't
you can't protect everything you can't
be totally inclusive of everything and
everyone you can't you can't tolerate
everything
if we're going to be really tolerant and
open
toward the
transgender students
then we are
not going to be so tolerant of the women
who don't want dudes changing in their
locker room
if we're going to be tolerant of the
women and protect women which was the
whole point of title ix in the first
place then you can't protect the
so-called rights of the so-called
transgender students because you can't
let the dudes into the women's sports
leagues and into the locker rooms and
into the bathrooms you can you have to
pick one and the biden administration is
pretending not to pick one the biden
administration is pretending to just be
really open and inclusive to everybody
man but they're not
they are tacitly endorsing the
transgenderism and they are tacitly
throwing the chicks under the bus does
joe biden know that he's doing that
probably not but the people who are
working for him and the people who are
leading him around by the hand certainly
are there's been a big debate
over just how far gone joe biden is some
people have argued that joe biden
actually even though he talks like he's
not all there and even though he seems
to fall down a lot he's still he's the
president he's the one calling the shots
he's not being handled he's not being
led around he's he's the decider
i don't think that's true i i
i don't think it's true
not not just because the man is
obviously diminished i don't think it's
true because the man has never believed
anything ever the man was always kind of
being led around if not by handlers then
by the prevailing political winds the
guy is just an empty suit and now it's
not merely
a matter of him not knowing what he
thinks about a certain issue now it's a
matter of he doesn't know how to act
when he walks into a room and we we just
saw this because of of a photograph that
the white house released zoomed in on
greg price pointed this out
biden was holding a sheet of paper
that told him
exactly what to do where to sit what to
do it
you can read it right there he says you
all capital letters you enter the
roosevelt room and say hello to
participants you take your all caps seat
press enters you give brief comments
the press departs you ask liz shuler of
the afl-cio a question
uh you
thank participants you depart so even
these really basic things you sit down
in your chair
you
stop making it so obvious that you're
reading these notes that we gave to you
this is pretty clear that joe biden is
being led around i do wish that whoever
gave him the sheet of paper would
instruct him uh on
how to fix the economy would instruct
him on how to restart american oil and
gas production
would we would teach him anything
productive
uh rather than how to comfort himself
around the press but that is probably
that is probably too much to ask he just
looks so weak he looks so weak because
he's frail and he's doddering and he's
stuttering and he's falling down and he
doesn't even know how to get into a room
by himself but he also looks weak
from the standpoint of policy
we have record high gas we've had record
high gas for what over 20 consecutive
days now or something like that i'm in
california gas is
seven dollars a gallon in some places or
more eight dollars a gallon in some
places
so what's joe biden going to do to fix
it well joe biden's plan is he's going
to ask the gas companies in a really
stern voice
to just to lower the prices
so let's be honest with one another
my message is simple
to the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now do it today
that's his plan his plan is asking the
gas companies to lower their prices
and then say do it now that's that's not
a plan that's not a plan by the way
they're not
it's not as though the gas companies are
just raising their prices to make a lot
of money
yes the gas companies want to maximize
their profits but that's not nothing new
that's true in ordinary times that's
true in extraordinary times and if the
gas companies were not facing pressure
because of things like the war in
ukraine because of things like increased
demand because of things like joe biden
shutting down new oil and gas production
shutting down new oil pipelines if they
weren't facing that they they would be
able to lower their prices they are
trying to compete with one another it's
not just like there's one gas company
they are trying to compete with one
another but that's where the market is
right now
and the market's there not just because
of these sad terrible turns of
misfortune that that have afflicted joe
biden out of pure happenstance these
things are happening because of
decisions that joe biden made
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america are you now saying we were
wrong to support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in
europe i don't believe that
no we're saying you should have dealt
with all of that stuff the first time
and not personally invited vladimir
putin to invade ukraine the revisionist
history that comes from this guy is so
audacious you you almost have to respect
the the sheer tenacity of it except
except to be fair he probably doesn't
remember he said it joe biden
one rolled out the red carpet for putin
by lifting the sanctions on putin's oil
pipeline the nordstrom two pipeline
which ukraine president zolensky says
caused the russian invasion so biden
causes the russian invasion
then when putin's getting ready to
invade he literally invites him to
invade and says well you know if it's
just a minor incursion into ukraine then
we're not going to really do anything
about that so he says you can do it you
can invade donbass you can you can
invade the eastern parts of the country
that's totally fine then knowing that
we're going to have the oil markets
going crazy he shuts down future oil and
gas leases in america he didn't need to
do that he just chose to do that
previously he had shut down oil
pipelines in america so he gives the
green light to putin's pipeline but he
shuts down the american pipelines and
when you shut down one pipeline it's not
just that you shut down one pipeline you
were signaling that the government is
not going to back any new oil pipelines
when there's pushback so he does all of
those things
no buddy when we're complaining about
this you can't just fall back on the
traditional democrat strategy of saying
that we're colluding with vladimir putin
you can't do that first of all you're
the one who was weak on putin and you
were so weak on putin that it caused all
these problems in the first place and
then you showed up and got tough a
little bit too late and then you made a
bunch of stupid decisions on on how to
punish vladimir putin that had no effect
on him by the way russia's doing just
fine right now we're the ones feeling
the pain
russia is not feeling the same kind of
pain that that joe biden
insisted that he that he would be that
putin would be and that russia would be
and so
now we're in this situation that because
of him the only thing that he can do is
say hey you oil companies bring down
your prices thanks a lot buddy tell me
when that's going to work
not very intimidating
it's not intimidating to putin or any of
our enemies overseas it's not
intimidating to domestic opponents
either
ron desantis governor ron desantis
absolutely crushing it as per usual down
there in florida he's pushing back on
the white house not on the issue of
energy not on the issue of ukraine but
on something that is probably
certainly closer to home for us than
than ukraine and it's up there with the
gas prices it is this insistence
by the white house by washington dc that
we shoot our little babies up with these
experimental fouchy ouchies that are so
extraordinarily safe and effective that
we all need to take 10 million boosters
ron desantis said no we're not going to
follow any of that guidance
governor ron desantis asked in florida
if he will be going along
with the white house's uh insistence on
shooting up babies full of
dr fauci's super-duper safe and
effective experimental vaccines that
don't stop you from catching or
spreading the virus and ron desantis
says no i don't think we're going to be
doing that
what do you make of the white house
saying that the state reversed on child
vaccine so the white house is lying
about it we are surprised
not surprised the white house would lie
definitely not surprised that legacy
media would amplify the lie because
that's what they do
the state of florida they came out with
an article saying the state of florida
has not ordered its department of health
has not ordered mrna jabs for the babies
yes we didn't we recommend against it we
are not going to have any programs where
we're trying to jab six-month-old babies
with mr mrnra that's just the reality
and i think what happened was they
thought somehow we would we would like
be be embarrassed by that no we're
following the data you look at these
european countries
they are
a lot of them don't even allow moderna
for under age 30 or they recommend
against it so that was always that we
still have not ordered it we're not
going to order it now what they're
saying is because practitioners and
hospitals can order it somehow we
reverse i i said from the beginning
they'll be able to do that we don't have
the authority to prevent it and quite
frankly if someone wants to make a
different decision i would just caution
people look at the actual data in the
clinical trial it is the weakest
possible data that you could possibly uh
see
no we're not going to do it i love that
way that desantis talks he's just so
confident about everything
he's just so you hey governor desantis
what should we have for lunch today
we're going to have cheeseburgers for
lunch okay and other people they want to
have a turkey sandwich and other people
they tried having pizza and that doesn't
work and we're not going to do that in
florida and we're not going to do that
for america and on this issue i'm not
making fun of him i i genuinely like
that kind of clarity and he's completely
right on this issue well what do you say
about you're not ordering uh vaccines of
fouchy ouchy experimental vaccines for
little tiny babies uh correct bingo you
got it
i know you're upset about it but the
report actually totally totally right
this is also really important for
desantis to focus on
because this is the distinguishing
feature
between him and trump
they
trump and desantis speak broadly to the
same group of voters they speak in
largely the same way they even use the
same kind of hand gestures
and the same modes of speaking they both
are talking to a kind of populist kind
of nationalist kind of new right
audience
but trump
backed the vaccines
trump wittingly or unwittingly gave the
stage to dr fauci i'm not knocking him
too much for it it was very very hard to
resist that sort of thing at the time
and trump went very hard for the
vaccines not to mandate anything but to
encourage people to take them
desantis
little little softer on the vaccines
and he was a little more reticent to
follow dr fauci and he was he he just
looks better to conservative voters on
covid
and so in this
stealth
race for the 2024 presidential
nomination where desantis and trump
they're not going after each other yet
explicitly
this is going to be the issue that
desantis is going to is going to run
with because it's it's by far
his his greatest strength vis-a-vis
trump
now
that the criticisms of trump on kovid
again i think it would have been very
tough for trump to actually withstand
the libs trying to lock down the whole
world and rig the election and kick him
out of office
but that's the most legit attack i think
that you can find on trump the vast
majority of attacks on trump are
complete bs notably the idea well
starting with the idea that he colluded
with the russians turns out there was a
total fed democrat hoax and we now know
that for a fact but two
the idea that donald trump tried to
stage a coup d'etat
on january 6 the worst day ever in
american history and if we were this
close to being governed by the
dictatorship of the horn hat guy but we
made it through so that that's obviously
completely absurd and and that never
happened
but did you catch the insurrection that
did happen
no probably not because you you wouldn't
have heard about it and it wasn't talked
about on the front pages of the new york
times and the washington post and blared
endlessly on all of the stupid left-wing
news networks but there was at if
january 6 was an insurrection there was
an insurrection
in the wisconsin state house
[Applause]
did you hear that if you weren't
watching if you're just listening to
this show right now i'll describe the
scene for you it wasn't horn hat guys
painted in red white and blue popping
cores wearing maga hats it was it was a
bunch of
left wingers wearing pink t-shirts
planned parenthood t-shirts they were
chanting shut it down
we don't care all throughout the
wisconsin state house
if january 6 was an insurrection
certainly this was an insurrection too
they are explicitly
trying to interfere with government
business they are saying shut it down
shut down what shut down the legislature
shut down the government shut down the
law making process the pros the law
making process in wisconsin's sacred
temple to our democracy no you don't
hear any of that because the libs don't
care about it because in this case the
insurrectionists are on their side
and they don't really care about our
democracy or anything like that when the
libs say democracy they just mean
liberalism progressivism leftism the
sort of stuff that they are after just
another reminder
not to take anything about january 6th
seriously at all it's a complete
political operation it the way that it's
talked about is a hoax is
is exaggerated to the point of of really
just being a fabrication
and people are still attacking trump
you're still attacking trump even in
that great temple to our sacred
democracy eric swalwell the man who was
almost president
one of the first people out of the 2020
democrat presidential primary who later
was found out to be sleeping with a
chinese spy who never stops stepping on
rakes of his own making eric swalwell
tells this harrowing tale from the
capitol
today i gave a tour in the capital and
was stopped by a father with his young
boy the father yelled at me hey swalwell
then told his son that swalwell he's
trouble he doesn't back trump i kept
walking and felt sad for the boy he's
being raised in a cult family
in a cult family because a republican
made fun of swalwell and said we're
backing the other guy we're not backing
the democrats we're back that's a cult
according to them the people who believe
that men can secretly be women and who
are chopping off the genitals of
children that they they're accusing
other people of being in a cult because
we backed the the republican who wanted
to cut our taxes and and let us be a
little bit freer
that's what they say and it's important
this kind of language is important they
it's not a mere political disagreement
here they are delegitimizing any
opposition if you oppose them in any way
you contradict them in any way it's not
just that you're kind of wrong and we're
going to fight you at the ballot box
it's that you are a dangerous
insurrectionist terrorist cult member
and you will be dealt with accordingly
now how are we going to fight back we've
got to build our own institutions and
you know what institution
i'm i'm a part of building that i've
been building for a long time and it's
really worked out thanks to your support
that would be us here at the daily wire
we're not just commenting on culture we
are investing a ton of money in creating
culture in making movies in committing a
hundred million dollars to children's
programming to take on woke disney and
all these other guys we need your
support to do it and and i'll i'm just
gonna make a personal appeal right now i
need your support because i really want
to beat ben on the membership numbers i
really want i just that would be so
deeply satisfying so head on over
dailywire.com knowles become a daily
wire member today join the fight with us
you will save 25 percent
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
all of you in the voicemail bag brought
to you by puretalk right now go to
puretalk.com
use promo code knowles podcast you're
gonna save a ton of money you're going
to have a much better cell phone
experience you can get all the best
phones all the best service and you're
going to keep my favorite segment coming
the voicemail back all right without
further ado let's get the first question
mr knowles i recently listened to your
yes or no with will wit on a road trip
and i would like to challenge you on
your stance on marijuana it is sheer
hypocrisy for you to sit there sipping
your martinis saying that weed should be
illegal
god created grain which you turn into
booze god also created grass which i
turned into brownies your justification
that alcohol should remain legal is
based on the second chapter of john
jesus turning water into wine and that
has been in our culture forever
basically just an appeal to tradition
not a moral stance
is your view really so narrow that you
cannot see the generalization of mild
natural intoxicants if so why do you
generalize to the view that all alcohol
is okay instead of wine only where's the
verse about jesus turning water into
whiskey
really good question you are completely
wrong but it's a very very good question
you say that my
justification for booze comes from the
gospels
uh in part that's true i cite it i mean
i
but but it's not i'm not arguing that
because booze is in the gospels
that is why that is the sole reason why
we we should have booze
i am saying
that second part that part that you kind
of glided over a little bit which is
and because it's been in our culture
traditionally for a long time
yes i'm saying it's been in our culture
it's so important to our culture it goes
back so long actually it was the first
miracle of jesus that's how far it goes
back that's how deep it is in our
culture and you're saying so you're
telling me michael that just because
it's traditional we should do it that
just because it's traditional we should
think about it differently than
something that is not traditional and is
some relatively newer relatively more
liberal thing that was introduced from a
foreign culture and my answer is
yeah
yup
uh-huh that's my view that happens to be
a conservative view
i do not have a highly ideological
rationalist view about which intoxicants
i support
i have a conservative view a
traditionalist view
a prudential view
even if you wanted to get rid of booze
it wouldn't work it's too deep in our
culture you could get rid of pot you
could suppress the use of marijuana in
our culture we did it for a very long
time and then the libs wanted to
legalize pot and now more people smoke
pot and i by the way i don't think that
they're
the same sorts of things
i i do think that
whiskey and gin and tequila and
everything
is
fairly similar to wine though the end
beer though they're a little bit
different but i think they're different
in kind from something like pot i don't
think all drugs are the same
marijuana and cocaine are very different
drugs one kind of chills you out one
gets you really hopped up and crazy
booze is a great social
lubricant marijuana really is not i'll
be totally frank with you i've puffed on
the devil's lettuce a little bit my
wayward youth okay not too much it was
never really my thing but i tried it and
i didn't like it very much because it it
made me i felt dumber and not as funny
and i i just i don't know i just don't
really like it and so what's my argument
for why we should suppress that and not
necessarily not totally suppress booze
that we suppress booze in some ways too
because that's what i want
and it's not just i'm not saying it's
just not just because of what i want and
my tyranny of the will i think we have
the right to set community standards and
we have the right to say no certain
intoxicants we don't like because of
their effects and certain toxicants
maybe we don't like but we're going to
tolerate them because it would be too
hard to get rid of them and certain
antioxidants we we sort of like you know
nicotine or something in certain ways
that that's going to be okay and we're
going to we're going to accept that
and yeah we do have the right to make
those judgments we do have the right to
set those standards
unless you're going to make the argument
that we should legalize all drugs
including black tar heroin including
fentanyl and all of that i don't think
there would be any good argument for
that whatsoever but it's not it's not
hypocrisy it's standards it's culture
it's tradition it's very very
conservative okay next question
hi i've been meaning to send in a
message for a couple weeks and i'm
finally getting around to it this is a
little out of date now but during your
debate with a girl over abortion one
thing i noticed you didn't point out
which i've seen very few people point
out is the false equivalence of her
analogy whether it's the violin analogy
or a car or she framed it the analogy
posits that allowing the natural flow of
events leads to death and taking direct
action by contravening nature leads to
life where in reality inaction leads to
a living baby and taking action directly
leads to a dead baby the false
equivalence goes directly toward the
pro-abortion side's deliberate reframing
of pregnancy is an unnatural occurrence
like a
parasitic infection that needs to be
stopped and i think a lot of people on
that side would be against that if they
understood where the arguments were
coming from similar to how they would be
for abolishing roe if they knew the
actual impact that will god willing have
it's a dishonest framing and i wish
you'd pointed that out during the debate
would your thoughts be there
my thoughts are you're exactly right
it's a very good point to make there
there are lots of problems with the
stupid violin analogy and all sorts of
arguments for abortion but i have very
little to add there i think you're
you're totally right uh one one of the
problems debating abortion is there it's
so wrong it's so wrong for so very many
reasons that one could be there all day
and you kind of have to pick and choose
but i agree that's a very good point i'm
glad you brought it up well well put i
couldn't have said it any better myself
next question hey michael huge fan of
the show super appreciative of all that
you guys do over there at the daily wire
my question for you is about religion
and spreading christianity this might
sound backwards but i find it easier to
share the gospel with people who are
atheist or agnostic than it is to share
the gospel with religious friends if
somebody is already jewish muslim hindu
or whatever their religion may be how
would you recommend sharing
christianity's message about jesus they
already have a belief system they
already trust god they already worship
regularly so how are we supposed to just
convince them to abandon their faith and
choose ours instead
thanks and god bless congrats on the
second baby too thank you very much i
agree with your perception i think
that's true that it is easier to talk to
atheists about god and evangelize to
them than it is to evangelize to people
who already have some conception of god
in religion albeit maybe not the the
correct one uh that's true in part it's
because the atheists are are just
so obviously wrong and they
either they haven't given the topic a
lot of thought or if they have they
they've really gone down very bad paths
and so it's it's much easier to do that
whereas someone who is let's say a
muslim or a jew or some
type of sect of christianity that you do
not agree with they probably have given
it a fair bit of thought and so
uh you know one wants to tread lightly
also because
we we need allies and so as a political
matter you might totally disagree with
the jews and the muslims and the
methodists and the this and the that uh
but you know that in this day and age
when
when belief in god period is so under
attack by the atheists and the
secularists you don't want to alienate
them because you it's just a practical
matter you you you need to form a
coalition to fight back against the
radicals so i totally agree with your
with your point but yes you do you do
have to evangelize so how would i go
about that well if i were evangelizing
to a muslim i would probably focus on
uh god as logos as the divine logic of
the universe
uh this is not accepted in islam in
islam allah is is totally um
transcendent in islam allah is pure will
so
i mentioned this on the show the other
day it's funny that this is coming up
again now
uh pope benedict puts it very well in
the regensburg address where he's
quoting a muslim theologian ibn hazm who
points out that that allah
can can order you to do anything allah
could order his followers to worship
idols and that would make some sort of
sense in islam very different from
christianity where
christ where and
god the trinity is
not merely will but also logic so that
would be one place and then you would
probably want to point to the divinity
of christ
which is
a point of contention with islam islam
views christ as a figure to be honored
but
they say that he's not not god and you
would also want to point to the
crucifixion because islam denies the
crucifixion and the crucifixion is
simply an historical fact so you would
want to point to that as well if you're
evangelizing to a jew
obviously you would just need to
convince the jew that christ is who he
says he is you might go for c.s lewis's
argument that christ is either a lord
the lord a liar or a lunatic
sometimes you will hear people suggest
no there's a fourth l he could be a
legend this i think is the weakest of
all we just have so much historical
evidence of christ
christ's existence and his life
broadly as we know it to be
uh so i would i would go through that
you might also focus on
the old testament the old testament as
prefiguring christ as various old
testament figures as types of christ and
i would focus specifically on the book
of isaiah if you're trying to
evangelize to a protestant let's say
you're a catholic and you're trying to
evangelize to a protestant you you would
point to the historical continuity of
the church and you would point to
uh the uh doctrines and dogmas and
practices in the catholic church that
different protestant sects might take
issue with and you you would want to
show their historical continuity and
their their place in the scripture which
is true uh there's some grounding in the
scripture for all of it um and so you
would speak in that kind of language and
if you were trying to evangelize to i
don't know to a catholic well i don't
know i wouldn't i don't think you have
to do that it's just my point of view
okay next question hey michael huge fan
of the show quick question for you
you're always talking about how if there
are things in our community state or
even the country at large that we want
changed we should contact our senators
and representatives asking for said
change
however i live in georgia so
unfortunately my senators are warnock
and ossoff
warnock is crazy ossoff is slimy and
unfortunately my congresswoman is
also crazy
luckily she just got primaried but i'm
still stuck with her until november when
warnock will be up for re-election
come november i will still be six months
away from being old enough to vote do
you have any advice on how i can affect
change until then or do i just have to
wait for the red wave that's hopefully
coming and being old enough to vote
thanks so much for everything you do
great question yes there is something
you can do right now right this very
second especially in
a midterm election year and in a state
where the elections will be tight you
can volunteer for a campaign you might
not be able to vote but you can
volunteer for a campaign it's really
really good experience one of the most
educational experiences of my entire
life was the first congressional
campaign that i worked on when i was 19
years old i think so i'd really
recommend that you do that and it's
going to be a really bitter fight down
there in georgia so you should you
should absolutely get involved in it all
right enough of the voicemail bag now we
get to the old fashioned old-timey typed
up mailbag question from david
hi michael what do you think about
monarchy i believe monarchy is the one
form of government which is best
supported by the bible and christian
tradition if you are not a monarchist
how do you reconcile this with your
traditional catholic faith really good
question i'm not
anti-monarchy
i know that some people
think that the american revolution was
about overthrowing monarchy or a total
rejection of monarchy i don't think
that's true i think a lot of the
founding fathers were perfectly open to
monarchy and there are kind of
monarchistic elements in the american
regime
there are three kinds of just regimes
monarchies there have been good
monarchies there have been good
monarchies and bad democracies
the monarchy aristocracy and democracy
the bad version of those three regimes
is a tyranny for monarchy and oligarchy
for aristocracy and
a mob rule for democracy that's the bad
version or you could have the good
version
in terms of the ideal regime i tend to
side with thomas aquinas as i do on most
things and
thomas aquinas has a very interesting
description of the ideal regime he
writes in the in summa theologia prima
secunde question 105 he says the best
form of government is in
a state or kingdom where one is given
where one is given the power to preside
overall while under him are others
having governing powers and yet a
government of this kind is shared by all
both because all are eligible to govern
and because the rules are chosen by all
for this is the best form of polity
being partly kingdom since there is one
at the head of all partly aristocracy
insofar as a number of persons are set
in authority partly democracy that is
government by the people insofar as the
rulers can be chosen from the people and
the people have the right to choose
their rulers
did you hear that did you listen to what
he was describing
sounds pretty similar to me to the
american form of government
which has one person presiding at the
head of all and aristocratic elements
certainly at the founding of the country
before the 17th amendment when the
senate exercised a role that was a sort
of aristocratic role there are other
elements too and then obviously a large
democratic role in the government too in
in many ways the american form of
government
is a reflection or pretty close to a
reflection of saint thomas aquinas's
ideal regime and it does remind us too
of what tocqueville wrote took alexi de
tocqueville writing the most famous
book ever on democracy in america on
both of those things alexei de
tocqueville was a a liberal and he was
pro-democracy and he was very
pro-american as a french french
aristocrat and he he pointed out that we
think of catholicism as a kind of
foreign element in america but actually
it's kind of the most american
type of religion and he actually
predicted that americans would that
would either become catholics or give up
christianity altogether that's an
interesting topic for another time but
as for the form of government
not the american forum at least the
maybe not the way it's functioning now
but the way that it was originally set
up
is pretty close to the ideal okay that's
it i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin